I need your help!
So I’m writing a book about ‘One Word’
and I’ve talked about One Word a lot.
Basically I believe that everybody has one word
that defines them
defines who they are
and when you understand what your one word is
what your core is it makes it so much easier
to make every decision better
easier in your life and in your business.
Some people see that message
they love it, they apply it immediately
they see great results; others are skeptical.
They think, “Ah, it’s just a motivating thing.
This isn’t going to take off.
This isn’t for me.
For me, BELIEVE isn’t just a motivating thing.
It should motivate you because your
One Word should be inspiring
should get you awake in the morning
should get you excited to start your day
but it helps make me understand
and make decisions for everything
that I do in my business
and in my life.
So if I’m creating a social media campaign
it’s got to be about BELIEVE.
If I am bringing on a new person on my team
they have to be about BELIEVE.
If I’m launching a program with a new client
So BELIEVE is the core of everything that I do
and all my decisions is filtered through that
and if it’s BELIEVE related then I can continue with it
if it’s not then it’s the wrong client
or it’s the wrong campaign or it’s the wrong employee.
And so I want to encourage entrepreneurs
to find their own One Word
and then use that to apply
to make every decision in their business and life easier.
So I have a few examples
that I am writing about in my book.
We’ve got 3M where INNOVATION is their One Word
and you know, you have to be innovative to work at 3M.
If you’re not innovative
then you’re not going to have fun there
you’re not going to be successful there
you’re not going to have a great career there.
There’s Jessica Alba who’s launched
the Honest Company
and so HONESTY is her One Word.
If you are not honest
you’re not going
to have a great time working with Jessica Alba.
You know, your business won’t last long
working with her
you won’t’ last long as her employee working with her
and her marketing has to be about honesty.
What I’m looking for is more examples
and ideally bigger name examples.
People who you look at and you can say
“Yeah, I know who that person is.”
I’ve got a lot of great smaller entrepreneur examples
which I’m going to share too.
But I’m looking for kind of the bigger name people
who have done this.
And so I need your help!
If you guys know of any successful
kind of name brand person
who’s used this in their business
or their life and just like a marketing slogan
you know, Coca Cola may come up
with a marketing slogan for one year
that’s one word but then the next year changes
and the next year changes.
I’m not looking just looking for a marketing thing.
This is the core of everything.
This is the core of how you define your life
and then live through that One Word.
And so if you guys have any examples
if you’re researching or coming across any stories
that you think would apply
please let me know.
Leave it in the comments
message me
whatever else works
a way to reach out to me
I’m pretty accessible.
Let me know.
I really want this book to help start a revolution
and really help people live their life on purpose
instead of walking aimlessly through it
and I would love to have you be a part of it.
So let me know if you can help
share some ideas.
I’d love to hear from you.
Believe!
Thank you guys so much.
I’m looking forward to your comments.
Don’t forget to subscribe to the channel
click on my face and I will see you soon.